hello we are so happy here today with
Arianna Huffington to talk about her
latest book third world America how our
politicians are abandoning the middle
class and betraying the American dream
Arianna it's great to see you it's great
to be with you why did you write this
book I wrote this book as a sort of
immigrant to this country who was
brought up in Athens Greece and was
brought up with this amazing idea of
America as the magnificent nation where
people from all over the world including
many people I knew would go to find a
better life you know that was like the
term associated with America a better
life and I literally remember going to
school everyday walking to school and
seeing a statue of President Truman and
he and America were associated with the
Marshall Plan with this incredible
generosity to the world and suddenly
over the last few years I began to see
something happening which was that the
country which was about the American
dream was actually not becoming the
country of downward mobility for
millions of people in the middle class
who felt that they could no longer give
themselves or their children the better
life that was associated with America so
I really wrote it as a warning but also
to show all the ways in which you can
turn it around because myrin the end for
me that's what the book is about it's
about the fact that we can turn it
around you know we have amazing human
and natural resources in this country we
just need to find the will to turn
things around you write about this
country your adopted country the thing
that you love most about it is the
optimism and turning it around so you
end the book very positive because you
do have that optimism but tell us where
did things go wrong you say this is not
a third world country obviously but
we're on our way to going there why we
are now way to going there because the
middle class is crying
blake and for me the essence of america
is the middle class the essence of our
economic prosperity the essence of very
democratic and political stability is
the middle class without a middle class
who become a country of extremes you
know they're always going to be very
rich people in this country and they
will have always been poor people in
this country what's different now is
that you have millions of people who are
no longer living the american dream the
expectation that by working hard you're
actually going to have that better life
for you and your family and you write
that Winston Churchill always said
reportedly America can always be counted
on to do the right thing after it has
exhausted all other possibilities have
we exhausted all other possibility I
believe Maria that we have exhausted all
other possibilities I believe that we
are now witnessing a very dysfunctional
political system that as Tom Friedman
put it can only produce suboptimal
solutions to our problems and therefore
and first of all as well as holding our
politicians accountable we need to find
the leader in the mirror as I say in the
last section of the book you know we
need to see what can we do what can each
one of us do whatever our circumstances
whether we are unemployed or doing
extremely well what can we do and to
rebuild our communities and one of the
issues is that people have lost trust in
institutions so as an individual what
should we be thinking about in terms of
truly beginning to turn it around well
first of all let's start with the people
out of work because you know we have
over 26 million people now who are
either unemployed underemployed or two
despairing to even look for work that is
a big number that is a big number and if
that doesn't count the people who are
still having their jobs but whose
salaries have been cut all the people
who have jobs but we are filled with an
economic anxiety because they're waiting
for the next shoe to drop and all that
is also affecting the kind of country we
live in but what we can do if we start
with the unemployed is recognized that
as Seth Meyer and his girlfriend who
started a group called who have time to
help discovered the unemployed have one
thing that most people at work don't
have and that's plenty of time so what
they discovered is that they can
actually use that time both to look for
work but also to help others so
literally they started this website that
I'd profile in the book and they make
themselves available to do whatever to
move somebody from their home to mentor
a child to to do anything that the fact
they have time allows them to do and
they what that does is it turns somebody
from a victim to somebody who is a
helper so the first thing we need to do
maria is to deal with a despair that
grips people to tap into our own
resilience and find our own strength to
survive whatever our circumstances are
and most people don't know that when you
actually have something like that on the
resume it's actually helpful to getting
you to the next step
absolutely and you know I have
experienced that firsthand you know I
work with a a group in South Central Los
Angeles called a place called home and
when friends of mine lose their jobs I
encourage them to go volunteer there and
at first there are gas you know the Fila
I don't recognize that the trouble very
in it and my feeling is that's going to
make it more likely you'll get a job and
it really does you know how they say
it's easy to get a job when you have a
job yeah well in the same sense it's
easier to get a job if you're actually
engaged in something productive well
when you're busy when you're busy
even if
not paid you know putting aside those
people who can actually take money out
of the equation yes and focus on
charitable endeavors it really comes
down to education you talk a lot about
education in the book and what needs to
be fixed why is it that America has
fallen so far on the ladder in terms of
education in this country well that is a
major problem because obviously as a
country we need to become competitive
again much more than we are
we're losing the game because our
children are falling one more behind our
public school system is crumbling and I
write in the book about it and move it
it's going to be coming out at the end
of September called Waiting for Superman
that is an amazing movie and produced
and directed by Davis Guggenheim who
produced and Inconvenient Truth and
featuring Geoffrey Canada who's done
this amazing work of turning Harlem
around and that movie is to me
emblematic of a shift in a culture
around education I think we've reached
the point and the Obama administration
is doing some really good things here
and Mayor Bloomberg and Joe Klein are
doing some great things in New York and
Michelle Reese is doing great things in
Washington DC so we have a critical mass
of real reformers coming together here
and this movie is doing two things first
of all it's making us sit up and watch
as people who care but whose kids are
trapped in in dysfunctional public
schools are waiting for them to win the
lottery literally to win the lottery
that will determine whether they they
are able to go to a better school
assuming they can't afford to take them
out of the public school and put them in
a private school and so when you look at
the fact that the American middle-class
dream has come down to a lottery you
realize how in how much trouble we are
and not only that but competitors around
the world are not stopping the way
America is slowing down in terms of
education their priority is educate
so I wonder the kind of structural
change that needs to be done for example
someone mentioned the other day why do
we have our students take off three
months during the Sun right on why are
this average school day shorter than
other countries are these some of the
structural changes that you absolutely
and also their schooling is to become a
place that is open all the time
because now you have so many kids that
literally have nothing to do after
school who live in areas where there is
nothing productive for them to do and
what is encouraging now is that many
people many politicians are growing and
less afraid of taking on the union's
taking on anyone who stands in the way
of real reform Maria this is a great
example of a beyond left and right issue
I think one of the problems were facing
in the media is that we try to shoehorn
every issue as a left versus right issue
and yet most issues are not whether we
look at education or whether we look at
Afghanistan we have people you know
let's take Afghanistan that I write a
lot about in the book because I
considered an example of perverse
priorities you know at a time when we
are facing skyrocketing deficits and
major needs at home who are spending
hundreds of billions of dollars fighting
an unwinnable war in Afghanistan and you
have people ranging from senator
feingold to George Will from the Cato
Institute and to progressive Institute's
opposing a war that is both unwinnable
not in our national interest and which
absorbs the resources that we
desperately need so it's really shifting
priorities as a nation away from some of
the things that are not benefiting us
and have tremendous impact toward the
things like education like
infrastructure that would actually
better society exactly I mean oil if you
take infrastructure
have a whole section on our crumbling
infrastructure now a lot of that
infrastructure that is now out of date
and was a creation of the New Deal it
was part of the Public Works program
that FDR put in place to deal with a
Great Depression so right now that is a
great opportunity for us both to rebuild
our infrastructure and assuredly create
jobs because these are jobs that have to
stay in this country and and these are
jobs that are going to be definite if we
only get off the political will to put
the money behind a real fundamental
infrastructure program so let's get back
to Afghanistan in a moment because you
do zero in on infrastructure quite
correctly in terms of why it is that the
richest country in the world has these
crumbling roads and bridges and things
that feel like they're about to come
apart why do you think we aren't seeing
more money move toward the states in
terms of fixing that infrastructure
around the country it's really one of
those things that we could all feel like
it's accessible and we get it just one
thing I quote Felix right on in the book
who's written a great book about
America's infrastructure again beyond
left and right you have Governor
Schwarzenegger and you have governor and
del who've taken a lead in sounding the
alarm about our infrastructure but we're
not thinking boldly enough I think
that's one of the problems we've come to
this crossroads where we can now just
solve our problems with incremental
solutions so if you go back to the
moment of the financial meltdown in the
fall of our weight remember when people
came together from both political
parties and across the political
spectrum and they said we have to throw
everything against the wall we don't
know exactly what's going to work what
we cannot allow
our financial system to collapse right
and after that we never really had the
same collective will to do that for Main
Street to do that for our infrastructure
to do that for education but that's what
it's going to take is it because the war
in Afghanistan a focus on war is sucking
out all the energy and money and
resources to focus on what's more
important there's no question that these
two wars first Iraq and then Afghanistan
have absorbed trillions of dollars by
the time we're going to be done because
we're not just talking about the direct
costs we need to talk about the ongoing
health care costs of taking care of our
returning veterans who are coming home
wounded and many of them incapable of
ever having a productive life so if you
add all those costs together plus the
fact that you know these two wars
literally took our eye off the ball of
other great priorities you see how
detrimental they have been but there's
nothing we can do about the past but
there is something we can do about right
now and yet when you and listen to what
the president is saying or General
Petraeus is saying it doesn't look like
the July 2011 deadline is a real
deadline you write in Chapter four who
killed the American dream
is the American dream death well first
of all as I say again and again in the
book it's all up to us you know it's
totally in our power to revive the
American dream to rebuild it and even
stronger than ever before but the
trajectory well no we are on right now
he's a very dangerous one and sometimes
in writing this book I felt a little bit
like Cassandra you know who Cassandra
was right but Cassandra was right nobody
wants to be Cassandra Cassandra wasn't
at all popular when she told the Trojans
that the Greeks are hiding inside the
Trojan horse you know they didn't
believe her but they were and the
Trojans ended up
and very dead so sometimes you need to
be Cassandra provided the emphasis
remains on the help I call it hope 2.0
because we heard a lot about hope in
2008 and there were many people many
young people who were activated and
energized like never before there are
many people who had not voted for years
who came back to vote so it's very
important that they don't feel
discouraged and frustrated they may want
to say that Obama let them down or the
political system let them down but there
are many many other ways in which we can
work to turn things around
but there is also the threat of other
countries emerging and getting larger
you talk about China in the book you
talk about other nations being more
competitive with America than they ever
have should we be afraid of this well I
don't think we need to be afraid
provided we are not falling behind and
because we're still the number one
country but China is catching up China
overtook Japan and iced the number 2
country and look at what China is
investing in its infrastructure look at
what China is investing in technology
Maria look at what China is doing in
Afghanistan China is spending billions
of dollars mining the precious resources
in Afghanistan and weaning and
tremendous heart sand mines there
because they're spending money what are
we doing
we the unintended consequence of what we
are doing there militarily that we're
blowing up a lot of civilians right
right do you think there is a catalyst
for change on the horizon what is it
that people will see to make them
believe ok I can actually make change
and this is going to represent a key
moment in time that is a very good
question the catalyst for change is at
the local level I'm not in any way
suggesting that we stop and
pressuring the government in whatever
way we do it with is by writing or
speaking or petitioning to do the right
thing but how yeah obviously the
government still has the raw power of
trillions of dollars in appropriations
and it's very important that the
government does the right thing but
beyond that doing the right thing at the
local level intangible of a measurable
way so we can see instant or if not
instant at least results that we can
describe is absolutely critical and I
profile in the book suzie buffett
because everybody has talked about
warren buffett and what he has done not
just with his success in business but in
philanthropy well his daughter has done
something very dramatically different
she has taken her foundation and is
spending it all locally in Omaha and I
entitled that section find your own
Calcutta because that's what Mother
Teresa used to tell people who wanted to
go volunteer in Calcutta she would say
to them find your own Calcutta look
around and there's there things you can
do and Suzy Buffett was telling me how
she basically treats her community like
her family so they're about to close a
local library she's going to give a
ground so that the local library can
stay open and kids are getting teenage
kids are getting pregnant she's going to
come up with inventive creative
solutions how to prevent them from
getting pregnant so start locally and
focus your energies your time your money
if you can and you have those resources
on an area that you know or your
neighborhood exactly and we we have
created a section on The Huffington Post
called third world America where we are
linking people to a lot of specific
things that can do and they're great
groups volunteer match all for good
where people can go online and find
whether passion
what is it that they really want to do
and that will add something you've so
important in their lives you know in my
experience I wrote a book back in the
90s called the fourth instinct in which
I argued that beyond the first three
instincts of survival sex and power
we'll all have that fourth instinct that
drives us to want to find meaning in our
lives to make our lives about something
more than just success and so ironically
we can take these very difficult times
and and use them to enrich our own lives
as well as the lives of our communities
it's about giving back it is about
giving back and I think most people
don't feel that they actually have the
wherewithal to do it but you're saying
just look around exactly and that's why
I started by talking about people out of
work giving back because after all you
would think they have to do everything
about themselves but how much time how
many of the hours of the day can you
spend looking for a job I mean there are
some of the people who are giving back
while unemployed who are already filing
hundreds of job applications it's not
like that you're giving up on looking
for a job but what else can you do what
else should business do when you look at
institutions that people have lost trust
in whether it's government whether it's
business Congress are there specific
solutions from that side of the yes well
I'm I believe Maria first of all that
innovation is absolutely key here and
America has been a country that has
proven that after the worst of times
let's take part Pearl Harbor when our
sort of military power was decimated we
put everything behind rebuilding it and
we suddenly had again on these aircraft
carriers these new logistical systems
and women working in producing what was
needed after Pearl Harbor and when we
decided to put a man on the moon you
know son
erica is geared to be a country of
innovation but there are specific things
here that you have to do and we can do
right away that's where governmental
says to play a significant role you know
there is this and this effort at the
moment to restrict skilled immigrants
from coming to this country you know
that doesn't make any sense because we
need to be able to bring in people who
can create jobs wherever they are and
there is an effort that John Kerry and
Richard Lugar are leading and to
increase the amount of visas that would
be available to interpreters who can
come from all around the world to start
businesses here and create jobs but the
people who are really looking at things
as a nationalist and even some might say
protectionist will say why would we want
people from other countries coming to
this country to take our jobs but what
you're saying is we need a whole bunch
of ideas yes we're talking about people
who come to this country to create jobs
or people who are and in our
universities and immigrants of this
country who go to school here and then
they can't stay here they get a great
education here and then we're asking
them to leave and go work in China or
India or Germany are we losing our
innovation edge I mean you look at like
what Moscow is doing they'd like to
create a Silicon Valley in Russia you
look at China they're ahead of us on
solar panels is America behind in the
innovation game we're not yet but we can
very easily be behind I mean the iPad
may be produced in China but it was
dreamed up in America and that's
something very important for us to
remember so that's why this is the
moment to sound the alarm because
because we still have the time to
course-correct it's as though we're on
the Titanic and we're seeing the iceberg
and there is still time to avoid it but
does business need to get direction from
government are we looking for specific
policies for example do we need a
manufacturing policy a lot of people
wonder what does America make well
that's another problem that you're very
familiar with which is that we have seen
a huge expansion of a financial sector
and very often the financial sector
instead of being a facilitator has
basically become a casino and it's about
gambling
rather than facilitating productive
activity now that is very dangerous that
has to change I mean I'm very
disappointed in the fact that the
financial reform bill that we passed did
not end too big to fail and the fact
that we did not reinstitute some form of
the glass-steagall regulations which
have really been very good for us is the
great depression by restricting risk
when it comes to activities that are
guaranteed by the government because
again Maria I mean when I studied
economics at Cambridge and I was always
taught that capitalism is the best
system in the world but it has to work
on a moral foundation and you know we're
constantly reminded of the fact that
Adam Smith wrote if the early of Moral
Sentiments before he wrote The Wealth of
Nations that Alfred Marshall and other
sort of creator of the private
enterprise system talked about economic
chivalry when we lose our thought then
the system is reduced to gambling so
you're looking at a country that has
advanced in some areas but really stayed
stagnant in other areas do you think
this country has to have assembly lines
to make something tangible you know so
many jobs from the steel industry to the
auto industry to the you know factories
making apparel have gone overseas those
jobs won't come back will they know and
that's really one of the problems that
that the Obama economic team
underestimated remember when
a year ago Larry Summers and others were
constantly talking about yes
unemployment is lagging but unemployment
is always a lagging indicator and now we
learned something which many of us were
saying at the time which is that this is
not just about a lagging indicator this
is a structural problem as you said
they're manufacturing jobs that are not
coming back and manufacturing jobs were
also at the heart of this growth of the
middle class that people could have good
manufacturing jobs and be able to save
and give their kids a good education so
we need some manufacturing bases you
know it it could can dream of new
manufacturing jobs and and this is not
something for government to do
government simply needs to create the
conditions for businesses to do that I
mean again let's take something very
specific a payroll tax holiday that many
people again across the political
spectrum are talking about providing tax
incentives for innovation for small
businesses for new businesses you know
new businesses are even more important
than small businesses in creating jobs
that's where job creation is really
coming from and that is what we need
more of we'll take a short break and we
will continue talking about third world
America with Arianna Huffington stay
with us afterwards and several other
c-span programs are available for
download as podcast more with Arianna
Huffington and Maria Bartiromo in a
moment the c-span networks we provide
coverage of politics public affairs
nonfiction books and American history
it's all available to you on television
radio online and on social media
networking sites and find our content
anytime through c-span's video library
and we take c-span on the road with our
digital bus and local content vehicle
bringing our resources to your community
it's Washington your way the c-span
networks now available in more
100 million homes created by cable
provided as a public service afterwards
with Arianna Huffington and Maria
Bartiromo
continues I'm Maria Bartiromo from CNBC
we're back with Arianna Huffington
talking about her new book just talking
about some policies that perhaps we
could see we did see a big policy coming
out of the Obama administration the
stimulus package in the book you say it
becomes a fiscal pinata explain well
what happened is really reminiscent of
what the English Prime Minister Lloyd
George said when he said that you cannot
jump across a chasm in two leaps so the
stimulus wasn't the right stimulus it
wasn't big enough
it wasn't targeted enough to get us
where we needed to be so basically what
happened now is that it has not produced
the kind of jobs that the administration
had promised it did not produce the kind
of infrastructure rebuilding that we
needed but it was a lot of money it was
a lot of money there's over 800 million
dollars of course are about a hundred
million dollars of course a lot of it
was in tax cuts and a lot of it was in
pork barrel projects and a lot of it was
good but not enough eight hundred
billion yes eight hundred billion yeah
so um but that's really what we're
dealing with Maria that at a time like
that we have to be able to get all the
way in what we're doing otherwise and we
don't have the multiplier effect that we
need and things are simply getting worse
how do you decide where that money goes
I mean the case you put forth in the
book about infrastructure is very
important because that not only fixes
the country I mean the infrastructure
the bones of the country
but it creates jobs immediately well you
see I think if we're absolutely clear
that the highest priority is creating
jobs which everybody's saying but people
are not acting on it you know the
president said in his State of the Union
in January that our highest priority is
jobs but that hasn't been health care
was the number one
yes health care which was a thing which
should not have been the number one
priority not should have been jobs yes
not not that health care is not a huge
crisis that we need to address but the
priority should have been jobs and it
wasn't so a lot of the political capital
was absorbed in health care and now
there isn't the same political capital
there to really deal with jobs and if
the reason why jobs should have been the
priorities because human beings are our
most precious resource we don't have any
throwaway people and when people can't
work and when unemployment is becoming
as long-term for millions of people as
it is now this is huge long-term
consequences because people lose skills
and it's going to be much harder for
them to reenter the job market
especially people who lose jobs in their
forties and fifties and I am constantly
confronted with people and who are
losing really good jobs we immediately
think of the unemployed as being
blue-collar workers which is very
significant in itself but here with
people were lawyers and accountants and
and engineers losing jobs and wondering
whether they're ever going to have a job
again and the jobs are not necessarily
the same jobs that were leading this
country as you write about after World
War two it is in some cases a different
skill set so what are the important
skill sets that people really need to
have to not just survive but thrive in
the next 10 20 years to make America
great again well the great thing is that
there multiple skill set
you know we're a big country and with
many businesses lots of industries the
important thing is to to see where the
good for businesses to see what the
greatest needs are and then if we need
to do retraining programs those should
be a priority and and also to recognize
as many people are recognizing that very
often even having a good education is
not enough and we now have tens of
thousands of kids who graduate college
and cannot get jobs youth unemployment
using a major issue yes and an
especially I mean I have two daughters
one and it's going to be a junior in
college the other is a freshman in
college and you know they get into
college with so many hopes and then to
leave college and not be able to get a
job is a huge blow
and you profile a number of people in
the book who talk about their own
stories yes people who lost their home
people who lost their job and they never
expected to be in that position in fact
the first person I I write about is Dean
Blackburn who and what is the son of a
single mom a teacher who got into Yale
so you may that's a lot of work right
right there worked for 17 years in 19
different technology jobs lost his job
three years ago and has not been able to
get another job and he he talks very
eloquently and very movingly in the book
about the fact that he used the thing
that he had to make a trade-off between
follow his dreams and creating some
novel technological innovation or
getting a steady job with a pension with
income income that gave him stability
and he did the second thing and he said
now you know we're beginning to
recognize that nothing is stable that
all this family picnics
now all the things that companies do to
build employee support is it didn't mean
anything and the thing that hurt him the
most he told me is the fact that he was
fired just in time so that didn't have
to pay him another month of healthcare
benefits and so he suddenly began to
reevaluate whatever he thought his life
was about and there are many many
stories like that I write about and
including Brenda Carter who after 13
years in the same job and in Human
Resources was fired and she describes
the moment of going to her office where
she had her life you know her life of 13
years from pictures to plants collecting
everything and not being able to find
another job so she's now making cookies
and selling them online and you know the
stories are endless like I mean there
isn't a way it's important to put flesh
and blood on the numbers it's because
that's how we connect with what is
happening it's hard to really connect
with 26 million people being out of work
or underemployed but the stories speak
to us but those stories are also stories
of resilience yes and comebacks and
what's great about America I love that
you know I have a series of steps in the
book of what we can do to move away from
despair and into action because I really
completely believe in that and the first
is tap into your own resilience because
we all have it anyway we've all been
through hard times and we know the
difference between tapping into that
resilience tapping into our own inner
strength and and when we don't so that's
step number one no matter what my mom
has always said to me everybody in this
life will be thrown curveballs it's not
about the curveball it's about how you
catch it how your handle the curveball
that is so
your mom is very wise we wanted to write
about it on half past because we're
collecting the stories because in a
sense I see the book as the beginning of
this conversation
so tap into your own resilience then
share your story because there is power
in sharing our stories you know you're
sharing your mom's story I sharing what
I went through I tell my daughters
they're sick of hearing it my second
book was rejected by 36 publishers
because you know I could have given up
but not number 25 right of the
rejections and said that's 18 I'm not a
writer
I should go to something else and so
that so tap into your resilience share
your story then the third thing is
improve your financial literacy because
a lot of people don't really know how to
deal with their mortgages their credit
cards the way the banks have always
hidden fees overdraft fees penalties and
now there is this amazing group that I
write about called hello wallet calm for
five dollars a month
it can provide financial advice so there
are these groups that are springing up
that can actually use the resources
available online to educate people well
one thing that I found is unfortunately
nobody ever teaches you about their
death so as a child we don't learn it
you really need that from home just a
basic about money why do you have to
save I mean that alone and then you grow
up and you're too embarrassed to tell
people I have no idea what you're
talking about I know and then you're
presented with this 30 page contracts
for your credit card or I don't know how
many pages as soon as you go to college
they ask you to take a credit card yeah
exactly and then you have these teaser
rates and then skyrocketing interest
rates and again you mentioned at the
beginning that I write how this didn't
just happen overnight you know you go
back to the late 1970s when it became
possible for credit cards
to be registered anywhere and just
charge the interest rates of that state
so Delaware for example have and that is
usually laws so credit card companies
could charge 29 and 30 percent interest
rates and you didn't even know it and
you didn't even know it because it's the
fine print exactly and you were given a
teaser rate so learning about all that
and learning about all these people who
are offering you things don't have your
best interests at heart learning about
all the tricks and traps it's absolutely
critical and educating our children
about it and one thing that I love about
what you write in the book and also what
you write all the time in HuffPost is
the fact that these are not right or
left interviews this is not about
politics it's not about politics and it
doesn't matter if you're a Republican or
a Democrat we all want the same things
for our families and we all nobody wants
to be taken in and you talk about saving
you know right now the saving rate for
people this is so minuscule that how do
we save again people are saving more and
more but how can we actually have a real
saving rate so you actually can make
some money from saving all these things
are things that are going to be
incredibly important as we are moving
inevitably away from a consumption based
society to a society based on on
different values people are really a
ting their lives right now after what
we've been through yes if there's one
thing that the Obama administration can
do to ensure we do not see this great
country become third world America what
would it be
Maria it has to be about jobs there's no
question about that but really about
jobs not rhetorically about jobs it has
to be bringing that same mindset and
that existed during the financial
meltdown when everybody came together
and say
basically metaphorically were not
leaving this room until we saved the
financial system there has to be the
same attitude so throwing everything
against the wall from infrastructure
projects to payroll tax holidays to
encouraging innovation to encouraging
and entrepreneurs who can create jobs
wherever they're coming from all that
has to be the highest priority and that
includes ending our engagement in
Afghanistan ending this kind of perverse
priorities that are draining our
resources and and being so detrimental
to our future and you and let's not
forget that payroll tax holiday that
you're talking about we encourage people
to keep more of their money and
ultimately what do they do they spend it
exactly and you know just to complete
what we were saying about the steps
going down to the growing of financial
literacy and move your money we launched
the project that we're calling move your
money so that people recognize that they
have the power to move the money from
from big banks that have cut lending and
move their money into smaller community
banks credit unions that are much more
likely to reinvest in their communities
and that's in our power to do this book
is as much about America and
institutions as it is that individuals
yes having the power to change things
Breanna congratulations thank you so
much good to talk to you third world
America how our politicians are
abandoning the middle class and
betraying the American Dream by Arianna
Huffington